У гостях добре, але вдома краще.
Так вирішили Катерина, Світлана, Галина і Тетяна,
які кілька місяців провели як біженці у Європі,
а тепер повернулися до України.
До війни жінки бували в європейських країнах,
але вперше залишилися тут на такий тривалий період.
І не як туристи, а як складова цього суспільства.
Оформляли документи, шукали житло,
відвідували лікарів, діти ходили в школу тощо.
Світлана повернулася з Німеччини,
де прожила 3 місяці.
Одна з речей, які найбільше вразили жінку -
це екологічна свідомість німців.
Сортування (сміття) - це окремий момент,
тому що після приїзду сюди, я почала теж сортувати,
хоча не розумію, для чого, тому що
в нас загальний смітник. Але це якась така звичка.
Спочатку було якось незрозуміло,
але поступово людина звикає.
І знаєте, що саме дивне було для мене особисто
- це пластикові пляшки, які потрібно здавати в магазині.
Ти отримуєш за них гроші
і одразу можеш зменшити свої витрати в магазині.
Також Світлані запам'яталося, з якою повагою
німці ставляться до лісів.
На природі нічого після себе не залишають.
А до чого було важко призвичаїтися -
це те, що у вихідні та свята жоден магазин не працює.
Це привчило продумувати багато речей наперед.
Катерина з двома дітьми знайшла прихисток у Відні.
Жінку найбільше вразила розвинена
система громадського транспорту.
Думаю, як вони до цього прийшли.
Я взагалі далека від якихось інфраструктурних рішень,
тільки як користувач можу про це розмірковувати.
(Транспортні рішення) у порівнянні з Києвом -
вони просто космічні.
У них якщо трамваї повинен прийти через дві хвилини -
ти бачиш, через дві хвилини він приходить.
Ще одна річ, яку Катерина запозичила б
у європейців, - це підхід до паркування.
Паркінги в них повністю платні.
Тобто в них немає ось цього нашого стереотипу,
що якщо це мій двір, то я тут землю купив
і маю тут безкоштовно паркуватися.
І спробуйте своїм сусідам сказати щось
- просто повбивають. У них такого немає.
Будь-яка ділянка, якщо вона не твоя приватна власність,
яка обнесена парканом, то все тільки платне.
З медичною системою у жінок були суперечливі досвіди.
У Світлани в Німеччині захворіла донька,
тож жінка спробувала потрапити до лікарні.
Однак без медичного страхування
довелося лікуватися самотужки.
Адже ціни на медичні послуги в лікарнях,
за українськими мірками, просто захмарні.
Ми зрозуміли, що краще отримати страховку
для того, щоб хоча б мати можливість
в разі чогось - ситуації можуть бути різні,
щоб нам надали допомогу.
Оскільки подивилися, скільки коштує візит
до лікаря - просто розуміли, що в нас Україні це просто рай.
Галина Євдокименко з племінником і маленьким сином
перебували у Варшаві.
З візитом до місцевої лікарні
у жінки пов'язаний неприємний досвід.
Каже: сидячи там у черзі збагнула,
що медична допомога у Києві
не гірша за варшавську.
Ми були четверті у черзі,
і просиділи там чотири години.
Дитина з температурою,
у нього такий сухий кашель.
Тобто бронхіт у нього був.
І ми чотири години сиділи. Він уже заснув.
Додому ми повернулися о дванадцятій.
Тут я можу похвалити Україну:
наші спеціалісти - супер.
Тетяна Лазаренко знайшла прихисток
в італійському містечку,
де віддала своїх дітей до школи.
Жінка каже, що вчителі й однолітки
прийняли дітей дуже тепло.
Ніхто не вказував на них пальцями,
що вони новенькі, що вони втікачі від війни.
Однак, на думку Тетяни, освітня програма
в київській школі - набагато сильніша.
До прикладу, у старшого сина сьомий клас.
У них немає фізики й хімії.
Є релігієзнавство, але цих предметів у них немає.
Вони їх не вивчають як обов'язкові за шкільною програмою.
Так, це мене дуже здивувало.
Я вважаю, що в них така трохи "лайтова" шкільна система.
Українці часто нарікають на українську бюрократію.
Але за кордоном збагнули, що там ситуація
не набагато ліпша.
Головна відмінність - нема корупції.
Ця бюрократія всюди, куди б не звернувся - всюди.
Всюди правила, але я не можу сказати, що люди суворі.
Люди в побуті, які зустрічаються, настільки відкриті.
Вони реально, як кажуть,
допомагають просто щиро…
З нами возилися - усі ці установи,
оці всі документи оформляти.
З нами реально возилися, тому що,
якщо подумати, я не знаю, як би ми справилися з цим.
Тетяна Лазаренко дуже сумувала за домом.
Досвід перебування в Італії
допоміг їй по-новому подивитися
на життя в Україні.
Якщо чесно, то коли ти вже порівнюєш,
ти розумієш, що - та ми класно жили!
Ми дуже гарно жили.
Ми не гірше європейців жили.
Да, є якісь певні нюанси.
У демократичних засадах, у законах, у нашій владі.
У всьому. Але якщо брати середній рівень,
то саме зараз українці дуже сильно
наблизилися до європейського.
На думку жінок, такий масовий досвід
тимчасового проживання в Європі
слід використати, щоб відбудувати кращу країну.
Якщо у нас є ідея йти в Європу
і намагатися бути європейською країною,
то, звичайно, так. Поїхали жінки, господині.
Вони поїхали, побачили, як там,
взяли в щось собі на замітку,
і вони обов'язково це привезуть сюди.
Ми ж переможемо!
Багато наших повернеться з-за кордону.
І ми повинні просто цей досвід використати.
Ми повинні одне одного любити
і піклуватись одне про одного
- не тільки, коли в нас якась кризова ситуація,
а у будь-який день.
Якось ставитися з піклуванням.
І це стосується не тільки своїх сусідів по будинку,
але й державних службовців.